die afg hat mein gesicht geklaut ich
hole mir zurück diese werbung hat die
afg bayern ohne meine erlaubnis gemacht
darüber rede ich jetzt mit dem medien
rechtsanwalt dr diesbach der kennt sich
aus mit bildern verletzung von prominenz
und prominenz das ist meine liga nächste
frage
die afg darf die das überhaupt nein das
darf die afg nicht die fdp nutzt hier
ihr bild und sie können entscheiden
alleine was mit ihrem geld passiert
insbesondere wenn es um werbung geht wie
hier und in diesem konkreten fall halte
ich das für unzulässig
ok dann ein glück dass ausgerechnet
heute der afd parteitag in bayern ist da
geh ich doch mal hin und sagt dass du
also ich habe einfach ein problem
seit es diese plakataktion gibt es gibt
anfeindungen auf der straße leute
beschimpfen mich hunde pinkl mich an das
kennen sie nicht
dann weiß ich mal wie sie sich fühlt
tatsächlich wir müssen irgendwie weiter
kommen was meine meine bilder rechte an
gehen es kann ja nicht sein dass ich ihn
als rechte rechte erklären muss
väterlich ich hätte sonst auch noch
gegen vorschläge für eine plakataktion
wo ich sage ist in ordnung
afg sachs oder für alf dpa afd saugt wir
haben auf deutsch unterrichtet den
grünen bilden wenn sie es positive
wollen wir können klar da muss man den
glauben
herr diesbach mein recht wurde verletzt
geld was kann ich da maximal
rausschlagen
also jetzt mal spontane reaktionen 23
maximal maximal 5.000 aber das ist
schwer
okay ich habe 5000 gehört sagen wir 5000
paar zerquetschte es klingt
professioneller ich berufe mich darauf
sie sie machen auch fotos von mir
ich gebe ihnen die rechnung wir haben
mal gesagt so summa summarum 5236 euro
ich könnte das auch schwarz machen also
ohne mehrwertsteuer nicht gern wenn du
irgendjemandem daraus eingesteckt wird
habs auch nicht gern der mittel die man
streckt sich eine möglichkeit dass sie
mir irgendwie entgegenkommen weil ich
muss ja jetzt irgendwie auf die 5364
euro kommen der familie zu stärken ihnen
nicht helfen da können sie mich hören
zum beispiel indem sie mir mut geben der
ist sehr schön dargestellt was
rausgeschlagen acht ganz gut sie haben
das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
also sie würden mir kein geld geben gut
dann müsste ich dieses auto finden ist
ja kein problem anders
und wer sind sie denn dass ihr konterfei
darauf gekommen ist sie wer bin ich denn
sie kennen mich doch nicht jeden dem zdf
auch nicht jeden kenne mich kennt man
noch nicht kennt sich nicht beim besten
willen ich sitze wirtschaftsjournalist
oder so was ja im weitesten sinne
journalismus wirtschaft oder was ja was
denn jetzt ja politik dann gehen sie
doch überall rum ich bin sicher gehe ich
habe fünf euro schon bekommen also alles
klar wir brauchen weiß noch 5310 cent
und jetzt gehen wir mal rein zum
parteitag mal mit einem verantwortlichen
sprechen
ich kann ihnen versichern ich bin
deutscher auch wenn mein name van dorst
erstmal ausländisch klingt lassen mich
ein nein kann ich denn nicht rein jetzt
wann dann gehen wir jetzt wieder die afg
ist für echte freiheit echte
pressefreiheit gehört offensichtlich
nicht dazu aber immerhin sieben euro 10
habe ich hier verdient aber so
kleckerbeträge habe ich dank der
zwangsgebühr natürlich nicht nötig
zurück nach köln